being that doesn't change of perspective
on things like in terms of scheduling
things that you want to figure like hey
if we're going away for her yeah three
weeks we won in two weeks at home were
simply definitely trying to be home as
much as possible
because
that's just what we're human being wanna
be around our family and and you're
trying you're trying to get home yeah
yeah all the time
and we've seen a movie of whom we
rebelled yeah it's like those three
little dogs a little cat who's the cat
it marks the cat guys love this cat one
of the caches got adopted actually why
some fans of middlin actually yeah the
guy had no idea and they got home and
they checked the adoption papers and
they found out two things number one
that Mustang likes to pee on beds two
that yeah the former owner was a member
of midlands so it's a slave again was
like because the baby had that she goes
yeah you choose the to this look at me
what are you gonna do you seen lady in
the [ __ ] right yeah yeah I said the cat
then she came I'm gonna ask you one more
time look I'm a dog guy sure I do want
to ask about your daughter like you were
very public about the medical emergency
that you're both your wife and daughter
well not very public you mentioned one
thing and it gets out there no yeah I'm
happy to talk about it now because we
were very lucky and I had a lot of good
fortune but yeah it was look it's just a
reminder that that life is precious
nothing's guaranteed and when it comes
to going through
the tough times you really realize you
know we were fortunate to realize what
an amazing community of family and
friends and fans that really lifted us
up and kept us strong through it so very
happy to report that my daughter's it's
very lucky and kind of a little miracle
she's happy and healthy and amazing
little kid so yeah it's good